the Joe Rogan experience that takes
takedowns change everything yeah they do
they take down they take downs change
everything I'm soda elbows in the clinch
so they had head butts head butts change
everything to you know I had David Leduc
in here from that way yeah watch his
fights watch some of those left leg
fights you realize like that's legit man
Rory once he was like he was between
contracts and he's like look me a
fighter let way I'm like why do you want
to fight
let way he's like because now is the
time or else I'll never get to fight
with headbutts
before I resign he wanted me to take him
down to the jungles of let me fight for
$10 against some guy we don't know no
medical test you know you're the
foreigner they wanna you know like it's
just he's nuts I was like no that's a
really bad idea come on I'll never get
to fight with headbutts or else I'm like
okay I hope you never fight with her but
they never comes well I mean you
remember the old days yes Mark Coleman
Mark Coleman used to take guys down and
smash their face with his head you would
hold on to their biceps and boom
headbutt you and punch you in the face I
mean a very dangerous attack boo kids
especially from a giant dude like that
very thing ya did
it's it's also effective I mean the
argument is look if you could punch me
in the head why can't I use my head to
hit you all right if you can kick me in
the head it what is so much more
dangerous about me using my forehead to
hit you with long-term long-term
repercussion don't you think I don't
know would it increase the level of
concussions or decrease the level of
concussion it's a good question for me
that's the major sin of our sport the
concussion the concussion I wish I could
take that away if we could take that
away I think would be better because
these fighters would be healthier
long-term I'm hoping that medical
science somehow steps in and comes up
with a solution that's legitimate
similar to solutions for repairing
ligaments right like if you have we're
not gonna outlaw heel hooks right and
they're they're they're a real
legitimate part of the game but if you
get someone in an inverted heel hook and
you crank on that [ __ ] you might rip
that guy's knee apart so that guy might
have to go and get everything replaced
and get
you know cadaver ligaments and the fake
ACL and all that jazz we're not gonna
stop that though it's a legitimate
technique the side kick to the knee that
we see a lot of guys use on the upper
thigh with it hyperextends the knee
there's gonna be someone who's gets
their knee blown out I'm sure it's
happened in other organizations I don't
think we've had it in the UFC if they
have I haven't heard about a Whitaker no
yeah
no I definitely heard it but I don't
know yet if it blew out and then he went
and did it in the rematch yeah well
right away and also Jorge Maz Vidale did
that too wonderful oh no dare until did
it - wonderboy oh yes yes same is true
that side kick to the thigh so if there
was a way that they could repair brain
damage the same way they could repair
ligament damage and I'd be so happy you
know I mean separately IV stem cell you
know some some way I mean they're
experimenting with things and I know
they're having some positive effects but
you know nothing is like hey you tore
this go to the doctor he'll fix that you
know we're not there yet because the
thing is like with with the headbutts
the fighters are gonna go and train
headbutts after right they're gonna be
hitting the bag they're gonna be doing
on this thing and what what is the
training gonna do to their head well
have you seen whether leduc goes does no
he does head butts on the pads so how'd
you learn combination on the path and a
heads okay yeah but let's see what he's
50 like 28 yeah exactly give him a call
when he's 50 let's see you know like he
won't even know what a phone I think
health first health first
[Applause]